Flyers also top 10 turn of youngest teams here's
tippet moving on in the back at sa rebound sa
another rebound it's loose and it's poked away
from Atkinson a couple of early bids by Owen
tippet he picked up his first goal as B mentioned
in the game against Minnesota here Thursday night
and York get on the for check gets that puck three
ainson rolls it right on through the blue and then
it tips fast Owen and goes to set her ice but
good first shift from the Flyers as they apply
some pressure man good job by tip it I mean you
can tell like he he scored that first goal against
Minnesota the confidence is high keep shooting
the puck a couple of really good chances early
turn over by sanim and in come the duckson stand
on a pass by Mavis gets shut up save rebound and
they score a broken play but it turns into a goal
as Ryan stro beats Arison up high and it is one
nothing anahe he's at one end of the ice a line
change and then a broken play here mavage just
bans on that Puck and really that kind of screwed
everything up I mean you think at that point a
shot would be on goal it's a scrambly play and a
nice play there but now it's lot knocking the puck
away lot turns the pass Forester back header
save go stall the rebound ends up underneath
the goenda wound up in the net but not the buck
Myers trying to make quick change here Fowler
tries to take advantage kns his way back back
in turns with it pass into the slot and vrono
scores power play goal the duts end their
drought and end the Flyers streak on the
penalty kill and one Fell Swoop and it's two
nothing anah one thing patrono possesses and
that's a real good shot that's his six of the
season during the zone and knifing through some
traffic from there he makes a real good feed
to Frank vrono who's left all alone in the
slot and one thing patrono possesses and that's
a real good shot that's his six of the season I
would say we won a silver medal but we probably
lost the gold uh at the world juniors in Geneva
Switzerland back in it was 1997 I think that
Silver's still pretty good heals it up the
power play is over the pass comes across for San
and he missed it and now he falls and it's white
jerseys the other way fires trying to get back
here's stro across and it's bunted wide by lome
and then off the back while he tried to Center
hit the back of the net mom again centered and
the shot stopped by no it squeezes in according
to the Ducks not according to the referee's got
it yeah the Ducks celebrate vrono thought it was
in but Frank vrono thought he had a goal and in
this angle here you could see the puck kind
of Rises up the pad of Arison and sits right
on the post and then vrono with the shove the
officials on the ice called it no goal and it
sounds to me like that will continue as there's
been no after review it was determined that the
puck completely cross the goal line we have a
good goal wow well certainly not on anything we
saw wow as it went skittering to the corner yeah
Flyers definitely have to reestablish their game
here as they are down three and scrambling
turnover here pass into the slot that shot
deflects it it's an empty net for Henrik he buries
it and the Ducks are piling it on now 4 nothing
really done a good job of winning Puck battles
and that is a battle one right there where you
strip the puck and create an opportunity see are
not able to get that puck out of his hands quick
enough and then the Ducks pounce get the
snowball going the other way who knows but
right now momentum is even in the duck's favor
Carlson turns it over there Tipp it trying to
race back the other way he's got a step moves on
in with Atkinson and he gave it to me SC Tipp it
to Atkinson and the Flyers are on the board will
it start a push we'll see Cam Atkinson fifth of
the Year turn over by Carlson not able to get
the puck in deep and that feeds a transition
the other way for the Flyers and tippet who's
on his backand makes a real Nifty pass over to
[Music] ainson apparently is okay he went over
toward the bench but must done a U-turn and gone
back in there he is Bunning the bucket Center
he got it to Walker Walker takes a look behind
him holds weights back to connecting he scores
they are back in it as TK pots his seven it's
42 Anaheim that didn't result in anything and
then the rush for the Flyers of feed by Walker
and what a finish fight connecting as he and now
Walker trying to work on Troy Terry a dynamic
player for this Ducks team old by their stand
was still a young bro and they work it in front
aison a big save stop calls him but then bounces
back they turn it over to zis there's been a lot
to like in this game so far for the Flyers I know
it hasn't been perfect but still 20 minutes to go
let's see if they can get that next one oh it's sa
in play thought the players were actually coming
to a stop there but it stays in play and here
is zigris cross ice and that's tipped away and
now concy tried a quick pass didn't get it out of
his own Flyers are caught stro into the SL zis he
scores reever zigis finally has
his first of the season it's a
power play goal and it's 5 to Anaheim
connect me trying to make the play a
Lon gets picked off and because of that those
two forwards are out of the zone you can see
they're thinking about a clean play out and
stro with the pick the find to zis and zis
with the shot his first of the year and that is
a back breaker here early in this third period
the Flyers come into this game mome who led the
ducks in ice time through two periods of play
you're so used to seeing Cam Fowler at the top
of that list there's Fowler seems like he's been
out there fouling a lot and now a two-on one the
other way as they move up Carrick has the [__]
Carrick the backhander and the traffic it's in
the net it rattled around and in and it's six to
[Music] Anaheim a battle one along the wall for
the ducks that creates this opportunity and you
can see sealer just kind of loses his spot in the
crease right here watch this battle one right here
by Carrick he wins the puck and that leads to
the odd man opportunity and sometimes you need
a little luck on your side and I'll say time
to Brink down low they sent it back on through
not sure if he was trying to bank that in or hit
ainson but it went on through now Brink to cier
and they score conne Tic Tac goal on the power
play and it's 63 and concy remains sizzling hot
as he has two on the day the second one not so
much but this one again Zone time opportunities
retrievals Brink it the heart of all of it thought
he could have shot the puck a couple of times but
instead he was looking for cier net front and
a real good play by C to get it out to connect
me Fross atson his pass tipped and now sanheim
is unable to keep it in it's Enrique moving up
with vrono going for the hattick and he scores
second hattrick of the season for Frank the Tank
and a short short-handed goal here the Ducks a 73
lead and here sanheim just tries to find a way to
keep the play alive after the initial pass by
Atkinson was knocked down and Brink who's not a
defenseman in a lot of ways could have held
his ice get right back on home ICE Monday
night against Carolina and then close out the
homestead Wednesday against Buffalo as they
go back to East conference play this will end
with stretcher six straight against the West
Bar shoty scores Joel Bary off the post and
in and the Flyers make it seven to four Joel
farby a real important player for this team
in the last couple of games and you can just
see his confidence growing unfortunately for the
Flyers his goal is a little too little too late
but still from a confidence standpoint I mean
you still want to see the P see if they show
resist dropped the puck here and this one
comes to an end an explosion by the Ducks